il
m
je
moi
bonsoir
merci
bonsoir merci merci de cet accueil
chaleureux et pardon pour cette semaine
de retard c'est la première de champs
elysées nous nous retrouverons tous les
samedis à 20h30 sur antenne 2 pendant 70
minutes environ divertissante après une
semaine difficile vous méritez aussi de
vous divertir cette émission sa modeste
ambition est de vous faire oublier vos
soucis en vous faisant découvrir des
visages nouveaux qui seront associés à
des locomotives je voudrais remercier
tous ceux qui sont venus assister à
notre émission dans les plus beaux
jardins du monde c'est un journaliste
qui l'a écrit ce matin les jardins des
champs elysées là où marcel proust en
1880 est menée à jouer au cerceau et cet
espace est très célèbre dans le monde
entier déjà l'espace cardin c'est là où
nous nous retrouverons les missions et
public
il n'y a pas beaucoup de place aux pas
nous en vouloir c'est pas baltard mais
si vous êtes patient quand l'émission et
f2 mais vers si vous nous écrivez dès
maintenant j'espère que vous recevrez
vos places je remercie la presse de
province la place parisienne qui est là
je le ferai plus longuement
tout à l'heure et j'aimerais pour
commencer que vos applaudissements
aillent à ceux qui ont beaucoup
travaillé avec nous ils sont un petit
peu tremblant ce soir car transformer un
petit théâtre en suit des autres
télévisions savait pas évident ce sont
tous les techniciens de la sfp
merci je vais pas tous les citer mais je
vais citer le réalisateur jacques
brillet lit je vais citer francis
remballe décorateur charlie garraud
dalta monsieur connaissait pas c'est lui
qui a équipé tous avec la lumière
il ya notre ami martial tuerie qui est
le directeur de la photo il a un rôle
capital à jouer ce soir et je voudrais
bien sûr remercié accueillir dans cette
salle nous patrons notre président
directeur général pierre des groupes est
représentée par joseph pasteur est
également présente monsieur jacques
nakache il faut toujours applaudir les
patrons aient vu l'émission